even with the rise of digital books and
a reduced sales of print books have
increased over the last four years by 8%
James Brown is at a small bookstore in
Leonard town Maryland with the effort to
make books as glamorous as movies JB
good morning Charlie how are you and you
are exactly correct and to paraphrase
Mark Twain the death of books is greatly
exaggerated
now unfortunately while a number of
large bookstore chains are closing
independent bookstores like
Fenwick books here in Leonardtown have
increased over the past couple of years
Charlie I met an impressive young lady
whose job it is to make sure that that
trend continues so these are the Sears
National Book Award winners were really
excited so Colson won the Underground
Railroad
when Lisa Lucas talks about books it
seems like she's read every volume in
the world and this is one of my
favorites Ibrahim X candies stamp from
the beginning which as the executive
director of the National Book Foundation
she calls herself a cheerleader for
literature why do you think books need
to have a cheerleader well I do think
that that books tend to get short shrift
in the cultural world and yet every
single child that makes it to school
gets a book learns through books we're a
part of everyone's life and yet it
somehow seems like it's this niche thing
except just because it's also good for
you doesn't mean that it can't be great
I'm brand-new Lucas is the first woman
and African American to lead the non
profit foundation which hands out the
prestigious National Book Awards since
1950 the awards have honored some of the
greatest writers in American history
William Faulkner Ralph Ellison Susan
Sontag dishonor but this is too much
last year Congressman John Lewis won in
the young literature category for his
novel on civil rights I love this book I
love this book so much but the
Foundation's main goal is to promote a
love of writing and that's why it hired
its youngest leader at 37 lucas
maintains a schedule that takes her all
over the country one of her main
initiatives is a book club
book up book up as a program that we run
in Los Angeles and in Detroit and in New
York and also in Huntsville Texas and
it's like a 24 week program where a
young person will work with a published
author a group of young people and we
provide all the National Book Award
finalists from that year in young
people's literature so they get free
copies of those books fiction nonfiction
poetry this program in Brooklyn has
clearly made an impact on these middle
schoolers in this program I believe I
read up to 15 to 30 books a year
I like visualizing what's happening in
the text and I like predicting what's
gonna happen reading is kind of like an
escape when you read you could actually
like visualize like a better world or
maybe some other someone else's life I
want a paragraph on what you think it's
gonna be about author Mitchell Jackson
runs the class and says he gets a lot
out of it too I'm inspired every week I
come in this class and I leave out of
here and I'm like okay so what do we
don't do next week how am I gonna keep
this going raise your hand if you like
books keeping it going is just what miss
Lucas is determined to do current
president Donald Trump has indicated
that he may be targeting the National
Endowment for the Humanities arts and
humanities how would that impact what
you're trying to do we lose funding and
for a non-profit and for a small
nonprofit I think people don't always
realize how small we are that matters
you know we have to figure out how to
make up that difference are you on his
calendar uh-huh ah definitely not the
foundation has a small 1.2 million
dollar budget and is only staffed by
eight people but Lisa Lucas has a vision
that is very big even for the stodgy
National Book Awards why isn't our
celebration as well known as the Tonys
or the Emmys or the Country Music Awards
I'm constantly scrambling to try and
watch the Oscar films before the Oscars
happen every year what if we did that
with books I think you really can make
sure that just like film just like
television and music and theater that
this is a part of our cultural fabric
Norah Charlie and Alex my three
well-read colleagues surely you know
that authors do get understated
recognition but Lisa Lucas is
aim is to make certain that they're
treated like rock stars and with her
passion and enthusiasm I wouldn't bet
against her back to you Nora
Oh brilliant piece JB I love that thank
you for highlighting all that Lisa does
anything that elevates the written word